an American tourist kidnapped in East
Africa three weeks ago is telling her
harrowing story for the first time on
CBS this morning
Kimberly Endicott was released after the
payment of a ransom and is now back home
in the u.s. she was held for almost five
days and the cop was on a safari
vacation in Uganda as Queen Elizabeth
National Park when four men abducted her
and her tour guide many of the details
are still a mystery only on CBS this
morning Gayle King spoke with Endicott
in California yesterday she talked about
the moment her ordeal began we're
sitting there and all of a sudden four
men come out of a perfectly square bush
that's in front of us and my first
thought was there must be something
happening behind us and that these are
Rangers and I don't know exactly when
why did you think they were Rangers did
they have on Univ their arms they have
guns so they were wrong and I've been
garlic trekking with Rangers that have
guns so that was my first thought so
there were no alarm bells when you saw
these men approaching you with guns well
there were but they were alarm bells of
something must be behind us mm-hmm
looking at them it became apparent
pretty quickly that no that's not what
this is they were not in uniform they
were a ragtag they were a little bit of
everything and then they made us get out
of the vehicle mm-hmm
so are they pointing the guns yes
they're pointing the guns so take us
Harriet tell us exactly what happened at
that point they make us get out of the
vehicle they make us sit on the ground
and that's where things go very I don't
know how to describe it there's really
not a word to describe what that felt
like it pure fear but that almost
doesn't do it justice
terror that's closer maybe but this
weird whiteness brightness it's a again
I don't really have a good word for it
but I just sat there and just faced
forward and sat there and and then they
went in and ransacked the vehicle and
took out whatever wasn't anything of
value to them and then came back out
there was a lot of commotion how many of
them were there four four of them four
and there's four of you sitting down yes
but the elderly couple I don't believe
were sitting down they were like in
their later 70s and the gentleman had a
cane and they let them stay and then
BOOM and it felt like a vortex sucking
us in what does that boom mean they
grabbed you really when I think back
about it did felt like fish and that's
it we're off now we'll see more of
Gail's interview with Kimberley anakata
about her kidnapping ordeal tomorrow on
CBS this morning one that description of
whiteness yes really fascists or
something beyond terror yeah yeah she's
still processing it yeah yeah your worst
nightmare